Improv can be found everywhere in
cinema. And not just in comedies!
It can be dramatic or scary, or even in
a David Lynch flick. Some of the most
famous scenes in Hollywood history
have been completely off the cuff.
Judd Apatow first made a name for himself in the
entertainment industry through stand-up comedy
and later through television. After working on
the shows Freaks and Geeks, The Larry Sanders
Show, and Undeclared, Apatow directed The
40-Year-Old Virgin as his feature film debut.
Apatow's filmmaking style has been largely
defined by improv comedy. As can be seen
in the Line-O-Rama bonus features frequently
included on the DVD releases of his movies,
improv is present on set in most scenes. Apatow's
scripts provide comedic situations and setups,
but he frequently allows his actors to play
around and generate different punchlines.
Improv can be found throughout the
entirety of The 40-Year-Old Virgin,
but one scene in particular stands out from
the rest, the famous waxing scene. As shown in
a behind-the-scenes featurette, Steve Carell
was actually waxed on camera to capture his
authentic reactions. Five cameras were used
to record the whole scene at once as Carell
and the other actors in the scene improvised
reactions in Apatow's typical Line-O-Rama style.
"Wowee! That–' 'I'm sorry' 'I'm sorry, I
really don't swear this much.' 'Alright,
you know what, I got a weak stomach.
That's all I can really take.'"
As Apatow explained on The Rich Eisen Show,
Carell, who co-wrote the script with Apatow,
insisted on getting waxed for real. It
was also revealed that the woman who
waxed Carell had never done it before
and lied to them during her audition.
"The number one rule when you
wax is that you don't put the
wax over the nipple. Because you
can just rip someone's nipple off."
Director John Cassavetes' [ka-suh-VEH-tees]
Faces was a game-changer for independent film
when it was released in 1968. Cassavetes
was already a successful actor known for
his roles in films like The Dirty Dozen, The
Killers, and Rosemary's Baby. According to the
biography Accidental Genius by Marshall Fine,
Cassavetes used the money he earned as an actor
to self-finance his own films. He was able to work
completely outside of the studio system and create
films that placed all emphasis on character
and acting while striving for authenticity.
Though it was his fourth time directing, Faces
was Cassavetes' first film to breakthrough
to audiences and critics in a major way. The
film earned three Oscar nominations for actors
Seymour Cassel, Lynn Carlin and for original
screenplay. As good as his starting material was,
it became stronger as it was explored through
rehearsals and on the set. Cassavetes gave his
small troupe of actors a concrete script
but afforded them the freedom to explore
the material from different angles.
Cassavetes himself contributed to this
improvisational spirit while behind the camera
by shouting out direction to the cast mid-scene,
which he then had to figure out how to cover up
in post-production. At over two hours long, Faces
is composed of just a handful of long scenes,
each which probe deep into the human psyche.
Angel — not to be confused with the popular TV
show of the same name — is a sleazy exploitation
film from 1983. The sensationalized plot
follows a 15-year-old high schooler who
moonlights as a sex worker. She finds herself
in danger when a deranged serial killer begins
targeting her fellow coworkers. The unnamed
serial killer character was an early role for
actor John Diehl, who would later appear in
bigger projects like The Shield and Stargate.
As explained by Joe Bob Briggs when he hosted
Angel for an episode of his The Last Drive In
series, Diehl was responsible for improvising
the film's single most memorable moment. He
had zero dialogue in the film, so Diehl faced
a major challenge when it came to making his
character memorable and effectively disturbing
in only a handful of scenes. During auditions,
director Robert Vincent O'Neil simply asked the
prospective actors to be creepy without speaking.
Diehl rose to this task by bringing an egg with
him, poking a hole in the top with a knife,
and sucking the yoke out before crushing
the shell against his mouth. O'Neil was so
impressed by Diehl's improvised audition that
an egg-sucking scene was added into the movie.
"I never saw it to fail. Give a man
something to suck on and he's happy."
In director Mike Leigh's 2004 drama Vera Drake,
the titular character is a working-class family
woman who provides abortions unbeknownst
to her family at a time when the practice
was illegal in the U.K. Imelda Staunton earned
an Oscar nomination for her lead performance,
and Leigh earned two Oscar nominations in the
directing and writing categories. While the
first two nominations were well-deserved,
the third likely came as a surprise,
considering the film didn't
have a screenplay at first.
Improvisation is at the heart of Leigh's
directorial approach. Staunton explained
that all she knew at the start of
the project was that it would be
set in the 1950s and that it would
explore the subject of abortion.
"'Ms. Wells, if you were to have the child,
would you keep it or have it
adopted?' 'I can't have it.'"
Everything else started from a blank slate, as
she and Leigh began rehearsing and improvising
the piece from scratch for a full six
months. Staunton had never improvised
before but dove into the deep end and
ultimately found the process exhilarating.
The film's standout scene is the birthday
party in which the police unexpectedly arrive,
and Vera's secret activities come to light. As
revealed in the book Mike Leigh on Mike Leigh,
none of the actors playing the family had
any idea the police were about to show up.
Only Staunton knew that her character
was performing abortions at that point,
and the shocked reactions of everyone
else were 100% authentic. In the book,
Leigh described the scene as the result of an
improvisation that ran for 10 hours straight.
"'I don't understand it.' 'I
don't expect you to, Sid.'"
Quentin Tarantino is highly
valued for his skills as a writer,
so his sets are rarely home to improvisation.
But there have been a few exceptions. One of
the biggest improvised moments arose out of an
accident during the filming of Django Unchained.
During one of the film's most intense scenes,
Calvin Candie, played by Leonardo DiCaprio,
rants about phrenology
and forcibly auctions off Broomhilda,
played by Kerry Washington. DiCaprio told ABC
News that a glass shattered and cut his hand
when he slammed the tabletop. The delayed
moment when he realized he was bleeding
was kept in the final edit, and DiCaprio was
able to stay in character and finish out the
scene as his hand gushed blood. The bloody hand
was incorporated into the rest of the sequence,
with Candie even smearing his blood all
over Broomhilda's face at one point.
It's entirely possible that his wound was
cleaned and fake blood was applied to his
hand instead of DiCaprio rubbing his actual
blood all over Washington's face. But the idea,
at least, stemmed from the unexpected injury.
From the very first scene of Apocalypse Now, the
production was already unfolding in an unorthodox
manner. The opening scene, which finds Captain
Willard drunk and freaking out in a hotel room,
wasn't originally in the script. It was entirely
improvised by Martin Sheen while he was liquored
up for real. During an appearance at the Dubai
International Film Festival many years later,
Sheen explained that the scene was shot
on his birthday and that he had spent
the entire day drinking before shooting
even started. He was open about the fact
that he was in the throes of alcoholism at
the time and didn't get sober until 1989.
Sheen described his mental state
during the filming of that scene
as being extremely precarious. He recalled:
"I was so fragmented, I didn't have a clue
who I was. I said let's film this. I was
so hopelessly drunk I couldn't stand up, but I
had a sense that I could deal with this demon."
He described his performance as being
less about that character of Willard and
more about his own personal struggle with
addiction. Director Francis Ford Coppola
tried to stop him in the improvised scene
when he accidentally broke the mirror and
injured his hand. But Sheen insisted on
finishing the scene on his own terms. The
blood that pours from his hand and
stains the bed sheet was 100% real.
The 1996 movie Secrets and Lies tells the story
of a well-off Black woman who discovers after her
adoptive parents die that her birth mother is
a working-class white woman. It became one of
the most lauded films of the year. It won
three awards at the Cannes Film Festival,
including the Palme d'Or, was nominated for
five Academy Awards, and took home three BAFTAs,
including the best British film award.
And it won for original screenplay. But,
as is usually the case with director Mike Leigh's
films, there was no screenplay when filming began.
Leigh spoke at length about the creation
of Secrets and Lies during an appearance
at Film at Lincoln Center. He explained that
he assembled his cast before any characters
or even any real semblance of the plot had
been formed, beyond knowing that he wanted to
explore the subject of adoption. Together
they improvised what Leigh described as:
"A whole world, from which we are then
able to distill and structure the film."
The moment when the mother-daughter strangers
meet for the first time is heartbreaking in
its realism and simplicity. As the
two sit side-by-side in a diner,
the camera captures their entire interaction in
a single long take that lasts for about eight
minutes before cutting. Leigh's improvisational
approach enables a lengthy, dialogue-heavy
scene such as this to unfold naturally in
a way that wouldn't be possible otherwise.
"'I'm a bit of a disappointment to you, ain't I?'
'No.' 'You don't have to say
that, darling.' 'I know.'"
Sidney Lumet's Dog Day Afternoon tells the true
story of a man who attempts a bank robbery so
that he can afford gender-affirming surgery
for his partner. Al Pacino and John Cazale
star as the bank robber and his accomplice
respectively, and the two had just starred
together the previous year in The Godfather
Part II. Lumet was a filmmaker who previously
held a strict no improvisation policy, but
Dog Day Afternoon changed his entire mindset.
Lumet explained in his book Making Movies,
that Frank Pierson's adapted screenplay was
used for the structure, but the dialogue was
largely thrown out in favor of allowing the
actors to improvise their way through scenes
with utmost naturalism being the goal. About
60% of the final film was fully improvised. When
speaking to Larry King on CNN, Pacino confirmed
that even the film's biggest and most iconic
moments came from improvisation. The most well
known scene where he shouts "Attica!" and riles up
the crowd of onlookers was completely improvised.
"Attica! Attica! Attica! Attica!"
The idea of invoking the real-life
Attica prison uprising as a thematic
connection to the bank robbery came from
Lumet's assistant director, Burtt Harris.
One of John Cassavetes's greatest achievements
as a filmmaker was his 1974 drama A Woman Under
the Influence. Cassavetes and Gena Rowlands
— his real-life wife and favorite leading
lady — both earned Oscar nominations
for their work. This character-driven
story of domestication, marital strife,
and mental health struggles unfolds with
Cassavetes's typical long and winding scenes
performed exhaustively with hyper-realism.
As Kent Jones wrote in an essay for the
Criterion Collection, the film defies:
"A century's worth of film theory,
screenwriting tips, and film school orthodoxy."
In the book Cassavetes on Cassavetes, the
director revealed that his unorthodox process
meant that A Woman Under the Influence
took more than three months of shooting
with six day work weeks to complete. Some
believed his films to be 100% improvised,
but he dispelled that notion, saying
instead that he always brought the cast
a complete screenplay. Only then would it morph
significantly as scenes changed and evolved.
He described the process as sticking to certain
lines while allowing the actors to interpret
them however they saw fit and then build upon
the material. He wanted the actors to respond
to whatever happened in the moment as if they were
reacting naturally in real life. Cassavetes added:
"It really is a product of a group of people
coming in and interpreting their roles. Really,
truthfully interpreting their roles.
Everything that Gena did she did herself.
I don't try and control the scene,
which is often confused, anarchic."
Kramer vs. Kramer tells the messy and honest
story of a couple's divorce and their battle
over the custody of their child. Dustin
Hoffman and Meryl Streep are in peak form
as the two halves of this destroyed
marriage. Both took home Oscars for
their performances as part of the film's five
wins and nine total Academy Award nominations.
"'I'm leaving you.' 'Honey,
please. I can't hear.'"
Robert Benton's Oscar-winning
screenplay provided a wealth of
juicy material for the actors to sink
their teeth into. But as a director,
Benton brought a sense of spontaneity to
the table that Hoffman fully embraced.
There are various instances
of improvisation that can be
spotted throughout Kramer vs. Kramer. The
most noteworthy ones arise in explosive
scenes between Hoffman and Streep. Some of
Hoffman's improvisation crossed the line,
like when he slapped Streep right as a take
started and smashed a glass against the wall
beside her head near the end of a scene without
warning. He also improvised some cruel lines that
doubled as insulting personal comments about
Streep's boyfriend — fellow actor John Cazale,
who had recently died of lung cancer — all to
force genuine reactions out of her. Hoffman
used similar tactics on eight-year-old actor
Justin Henry as well, who became the youngest
Oscar nominee ever. Henry was never given a
script, and his scenes were entirely improvised.
The action-packed Police Story is a
Hong Kong kung-fu crime film from 1985,
filled with goofy humor and jaw-dropping
stunts in equal measure. Jackie Chan
not only stars in the lead role but
also co-wrote and directed the film,
delivering one of the greatest films in
his all-around impressive body of work.
The film's lengthy opening action sequence begins
with a shootout, moves to an explosive car chase,
then progresses to Chan chasing a double-decker
bus on foot. All of these dangerous stunts were
precisely coordinated, but the stunt that
concluded the sequence didn't go according
to plan. As Chan himself explained, when the
bus stops, three stuntmen were supposed to
crash through the windows and land on the
car parked in front of it. But the bus's
brakes didn't act as anticipated and sent the
stunt performers through the windows too early.
Landing atop a car might sound extremely painful,
but the slight springiness to the metal and the
added height of the vehicle were preferable to
slamming directly onto the concrete far
below, which is what ended up happening.
Rather than squander the stunt team's pain
by calling cut, Chan was able to stay in
character and improvise the rest of the shot,
incorporating the accident into the final film.
After the big-budget disaster of his 1984 Dune
adaptation, David Lynch reteamed with star Kyle
MacLachlan for a smaller film with a twisted
original script that only Lynch could deliver.
The 1986 film Blue Velvet is a nightmarish descent
into the disturbing crimes and perversions that
fester below the surface of suburban America,
as told with Lynch's signature surrealistic
style. His work rarely adheres to the rules
of the natural world and is often derived
from dreams, the subconscious, and through
his practice of transcendental meditation.
In Blue Velvet, music is a key component and
even inspired its title, with the Bobby Vinton
song of the same name sung by Isabella
Rossellini in the film. Another important
musical number occurs when Dean Stockwell
performs Roy Orbison's "In Dreams" into a
construction light. In the book Lynch on
Lynch, it was revealed that a version of
this scene was planned but that the end
result came about through improvisation.
The initial plan was for Dennis Hopper to
perform the song as the film's villain,
Frank Booth. Hopper and Stockwell began
singing it together on set despite only
Hopper being on camera. Hopper was so taken
by Stockwell's performance that he stopped
singing and simply watched him finish the song.
Lynch loved the result and reworked the scene.
The choice to sing into a construction light
was another spontaneous decision, as Stockwell
mistakenly grabbed a light used by the crew
instead of the prop he was supposed to use.
After making Husbands and before making A Woman
Under the Influence, director John Cassavetes
released Minnie and Moskowitz. The film utilized
his unique hyper-naturalistic style but injected
it into the structure of an old-school screwball
romantic comedy that eschewed all the rules.
The titular characters of Minnie, played by Gena
Rowlands, and Moskowitz, played by Seymour Cassel,
form a troubled romance as colorful supporting
characters breeze in and out of their lives.
As with his other films, Cassavetes gave
his actors as much latitude as possible to
flesh out the characters themselves
as they were shooting their scenes.
But by placing his improvisational style
into a more conventional structure – the
framework of a traditional romantic
comedy — Cassavetes was able to break
through to wider audiences with Minnie and
Moskowitz as opposed to his other films,
which were frequently labeled by his critics
as self-indulgent and meandering to a fault.
Given how meticulously choreographed
and executed the John Wick movies are,
it might come as a surprise to learn that
improvisation still made its way into John Wick:
Chapter 3 — Parabellum. Mark Dacascos, who plays
the film's lead villain Zero, revealed to Vulture
that his character was written to be familiar with
Mr. Wick's reputation. But Dacascos wanted to push
that part of his character further. In their first
face-to-face scene, Dacascos began to improvise by
moving uncomfortably close to Keanu Reeves, to the
point that their legs were touching. He explained:
"I could feel Keanu's energy, it
felt like his energy was saying,
'What the f—,' because my leg is touching his.
Big kudos and credit to Keanu and Chad [Stahelski,
director] because either of them could
have said, 'Cut' [...] But Chad let it go,
and Keanu stayed in character."
As the scene went on, Reeves picked
up on what Dacascos was doing and joined in
until the scene was finished. Dacascos recalled:
"There's a beat, and I hear Chad from the back go,
'I love it. We're doing it.' And
that's how that take evolved."
Mikey and Nicky is an exploration of a toxic
friendship from writer-director Elaine May.
The film follows two low-level gangsters
with a long and complicated history that
bubbles back to the surface when Nicky becomes
an assassination target. May had a background
in improvisation as part of the improv comedy
duo Nichols and May, so her casting improvisers
Peter Falk and John Cassavetes in the
two titular roles was no coincidence.
May's screenplay was written in an unusual
style that was conducive to her and her
cast's exploratory approach. The opening
sequence is a perfect example of this,
as the first four-and-a-half pages are
written more like a book than a script.
Background information, character details, and
future-tense occurrences are described without
explicitly telling the actors what to do or
how. The first lines of the film are Nicky
giving Mikey instructions over the phone, but the
dialogue itself was left completely unscripted.
May's process for making the film typically
involved letting Falk and Cassavetes improvise
with three cameras rolling. It wasn't
uncommon for multiple hours to pass
between May calling "action" and "cut." Though
the film is only an hour and 46 minutes long,
May shot a staggering 1.4 million feet of
film stock, which is equivalent to around
14,000 hours' worth of footage.
Kill Zone is a gritty police thriller
from Hong Kong. Simon Yam and Donnie
Yen star as a police inspector nearing
retirement and his incoming replacement,
both of whom become obsessed with taking down a
crime kingpin played by martial arts legend Sammo
Hung. The first huge action scene finds Donnie
Yen squaring off in an alleyway against Wu Jing,
who would later star in and direct China's highest
grossing film of all time, Wolf Warrior 2. Given
the intense coordination and danger involved,
it's exceptionally rare to find improvisation
in a fight sequence, but Kill Zone pulled it off.
As shown in the behind-the-scenes documentary,
the alleyway baton-vs-knife fight
featured extensive improvisation.
But the alleyway sequence wasn't in the script,
and the first cut of the film had been completed
without any fight scenes in it. Yen realized the
movie was in need of action, so he took it upon
himself to get additional funding and spend five
days shooting the alleyway fight on the fly. Yen
explained that he would have certain moves planned
out in his head but that he would implement them
in different orders and combinations while
sparring with Jing on camera. He explained:
"It's like musicians, you jam, you
know? You see all these movements,
they're really not choreographed."
Director Mike Leigh and star David Thewlis both
took home the top honors in their categories at
the Cannes Film Festival for their work on the
1993 drama Naked. Thewlis plays a nihilistic
drifter, conspiracy theorist, and all-around
terrible person in a loose narrative that follows
his exploits through London in the middle of the
night. As is always the case with Leigh's films,
the entire project was born from extensive
improvisation, research, and rehearsals.
He and Thewlis had collaborated twice
before on other projects but Thewlis's
screentime was brief on both occasions.
With virtually nothing other than wanting
to work together again on a project
in which Thewlis would be the lead,
the two generated the main character and
improvised a story through multiple months
of rehearsals. Leigh explained that he
treated the character of Johnny as a
receptacle for information and piled mountains
of research about various subjects onto Thewlis.
This all came in handy and allowed Thewlis to
go wild in the memorable sequence in which he
befriends a security guard and rants about
numerous subjects and conspiracy theories
such as the impending Y2K hysteria and
the theory that barcodes were satanic.
With 11 Oscar nominations and six wins including
best picture, The Godfather Part II managed the
miraculous feat of outdoing the original
best picture-winning The Godfather at the
Academy Awards. Released just two short
years later, this follow-up acts as both
a sequel and a prequel to the first film as it
tracks Michael Corleone's growing ruthlessness
while showcasing Vito Corleone's rise
to power through multiple flashbacks.
One of the film's strongest and most emotional
scenes is the final confrontation between Michael
and his older brother Fredo, played by John
Cazale. The scene was already powerful in the
script, but it was made infinitely stronger
through an element that wasn't on the page.
Cazale's choice to play the entire scene from
a bouncy, low-backed chair was a perfect fit
for the scene. The awkward position made his
outrage all the more pathetic and ineffectual.
"I'm smart and I want respect!"
On a commentary track recorded for the
physical media release of the film,
director Francis Ford Coppola
explained that the chair just
happened to be on the set and wound up
becoming a vital part of it, saying:
"There was something about that chair that
worked so great for the scene ... the chair
just kind of made him be so limp and springy
... sometimes you get lucky with a chair."
They Live is a 1988 sci-fi action classic
from director John Carpenter. Roddy Piper
plays a homeless man who comes into possession
of a pair of sunglasses that reveals the world
as it truly is, a capitalist dystopia
ruled by aliens disguised as humans.
"What's your problem?"
And both of the film's two most famous
scenes were the result of improvisation.
If there is any scene from They Live that
the average person will be familiar with,
it's the one featuring the iconic line:
"I have come here to chew bubblegum and
kick ass. And I'm all outta bubblegum."
And Piper completely improvised the line.
The other well-known scene is the back alley
beatdown between Piper and co-star Keith David.
In an interview with YouTuber Rossatron, Carpenter
and David explained that the fight scene was
shoved into the movie after Piper had been cast.
Piper was better known as a wrestler with the WWF,
where he went by the name "Rowdy" Roddy
Piper, and Carpenter figured that a movie
starring a professional wrestler ought to
make use of his physical abilities in a
big fight scene that lasts for a whopping six
minutes. The 1988 shooting script simply read:
"And we begin the fight in the alley, as Nada
and Frank go at each other..." followed by three
mostly blank pages on which only "The fight.
Continued," and "The Fight. Still Continued"
is written, with all of the intricacies
of the clash being worked out on location.